[Music]
straight ahead
all lawn crime daily meghan markle wins
a privacy case
over a uk tabloid publishing her letter
to her estranged father
a texas mother tackles a suspected
peeping tom sending him straight to the
slammer
the senate votes to acquit former
president trump of inciting an
insurrection
but could he still be facing criminal
prosecution didn't get away with
anything
yet the truth in this case is in the
lies
did wisconsin man kill his wife then
hide her body to be with his new
girlfriend
or did she disappear on her own nearly
eight years ago the only person to know
what's happened to victoria
is victoria law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
british royal couple meghan markle and
prince harry announced they're expecting
baby number two
and the news comes on the heels of a
legal victory for the celebrity parents
a uk judge has ruled the publication
mail on sunday
violated the duchess of sussex privacy
by publishing a handwritten letter to
her estranged father
extracts from meghan markle's 2018
letter to her father
after he failed to attend her wedding to
prince harry made headlines in the daily
mail
in february 2019. in the letter she
wrote to her father thomas markle
that he had broken her heart into a
million pieces by speaking to the
tabloids while refusing to take her
phone calls
markle and prince harry then sued the
tabloid's owner associated newspapers
in october 2019 for misuse of private
information
copyright infringement and breach of the
data protection act the couple saying at
the time
it was part of a war against a campaign
of misrepresentation against megan
now the judge has ruled publishing the
letter was quote manifestly excessive
and hence
unlawful finding that the letter was
about her feeling of anguish about her
father's behavior
these are inherently private and
personal matters the mail of sunday
released a statement after the ruling
saying they were surprised and
disappointed at being denied the chance
to have a full trial joining us today is
the president and co-founder of west
coast trial lawyers
nima romani as well as terry austin
terry
from my understanding if this was done
in the united states
the results would have been a little
different right absolutely if it had
been done here in the united states the
standards for a public figure
are completely different for a private
citizen so
here the public has a right to know and
that outweighs the privacy right
that a public figure may have now having
said that
a public figure can sue for defamation
but he or she would have to show that
there was a false statement
and that it was made with malice it was
published and that
that caused harm to the reputation so
you can prevail but it's much more
difficult here
nima with all that being said do you
foresee maybe perhaps
more uk tabloids potentially publishing
their stories in the united states to
avoid all of this
the defamation laws and privacy laws
are much more favorable to the media
over here
that's what actually folks suing for
defamation like to sue
in both the uk and other countries in
europe
it's surprising actually johnny depp
filed his recent lawsuit out there and
he lost but
no question that the media prefers our
first amendment protections here in the
united states and
certain states such as california have
even additional protections that allow
for attorneys fees if you actually try
to bring these cases forward
in violation of the first amendment yeah
it's going to be really interesting to
see
how this works out because if that does
play out terry real quick
british tabloid or uk tabloid publishes
in in the us
do they still have those protections or
not do you think that'd be an
interesting question
well i think that the media has far more
protections here in the u.s and i think
they can say
basically anything they want to say so
yeah i think it's different here
gotcha thank you both turning now to
other top legal news making headlines
father rapper nicki minaj was killed in
a hit and run crash in long island new
york
the nassau county police department says
robert mirage was walking along a road
around 6 pm
on friday a car apparently struck him
and kept on driving
the 64 year old was taken to a hospital
and pronounced dead on saturday
police are asking any witnesses to the
fatal crash to come forward
former nfl cornerback adam pakman jones
has been arrested for misdemeanor
assault in cincinnati ohio
jones is accused of punching and kicking
a person in the head until they were
unconscious
he's had several past run-ins with the
law including disorderly conduct charges
and pleading guilty to cheating at
gambling jones has played for the
cincinnati bengals
denver broncos dallas cowboys and
tennessee titans
he retired from the nfl in 2019
a former rutgers university basketball
player is accused of killing a woman
working in a nightclub in mexico 26 year
old logan kelly
is being held on suspicion of murder in
tijuana tijuana police say kelly walked
up behind the victim
sliced her neck with a knife and tried
to flee 19-year-old
isis montoya reportedly died on the
scene
a mom in texas is being credited for her
quick moves after tackling a man
suspected
of peeping in in her daughter's window
late jackson police dash cam video
captured phyllis pina bringing the
suspect to the ground
police say pina called police to report
a man looking into her 15 year old's
room
police arrived and saw zane hawkins
nearby hawkins ran
and that's when pina sprang into action
after an officer reportedly told pena
she made a pretty good tackle
hawkins was arrested on charges of
possession of a controlled substance and
evading and resisting arrest
police in new york city announced the
arrest of the so-called subway slasher
the nypd says roger berto lopez is
behind a string of attacks that left two
people dead
and injured two more roger bertol lopez
faces two charges of second-degree
murder
two counts of attempted second-degree
murder and one charge of first degree
murder
police say the four victims are believed
to be homeless the stabbing
and arrest all occurred within 24 hours
a 67 year old male was stabbed by an
unknown male
by an unknown male he was treated at an
area hospital
that night at approximately 11 29 pm an
adult male
was pronounced deceased on the a train
at the far rockaway
mott avenue train station in the
confines of the 101 precinct
he suffered stab wounds to his neck and
torso
about two hours later at approximately 1
15 a.m
an unconscious 44 year old female was
found inside of a train
in inwood 207th street ace a subway
station with multiple stab wounds she
was removed to an area hospital where
she was pronounced deceased
at approximately 1 28 a.m police
responded to
659 west 181st street where they found a
43 year old
male who was stabbed at the 181 street a
line subway station he was treated at an
area hospital and is listed in stable
condition
three of these incidents appear to be
connected and the detective bureau is
looking into the possibility
that all four could have been committed
by one individual
still ahead of law and crime daily our
first live trial of the year is underway
but first what the acquittal of former
president trump means
for other investigations should he be
worried for possible criminal charges
or extra analysis next
[Music]
the senate acquitted former president
trump on one count of incitement of
insurrection
over the weekend law encrimes angenette
levy is here to tell us
why one senate leader says trump's legal
troubles are far from over
yeah brian that vote fell right along
party lines with just seven republicans
joining democrats and voting to convict
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
then
laid in to the former president after
the vote
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
despite voting to acquit former
president trump of incitement of
insurrection
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
lambasted trump for his actions
and language some of the rioters who
stormed the capitol
threatened to kill house speaker nancy
pelosi and vice president mike pence
they did this because they'd been
fed wild falsehoods
by the most powerful man on earth
because he was angry he lost an election
the republicans who voted to acquit said
they did so largely on constitutional
grounds
believing a former president cannot be
impeached mcconnell warned trump's still
in legal jeopardy
we have a criminal justice system in
this country
we have civil litigation and former
presidents are not immune from being
accountable by
either one but will trump actually face
federal criminal charges former
assistant u.s attorney gene rossi
believes it's likely it's not just his
speech
although that is bad it's what donald
trump
and his crew did in the white house
before during and after the attack
that matters it's not just the speech
but another former federal prosecutor
doesn't believe trump will be charged
i think it's very unlikely even though
the president can be charged it's an
entirely different question of whether
he will be charged
i think this new president wants to move
forward does not want to create the
precedent
of charging political opponents who have
lost elections first amendment expert
and father of law and crimes founder
floyd abrams says incitement cases can
be difficult to prove
given the first amendment protections
afforded by brandenburg v
ohio and not knowing trump's true intent
i would listen hard if someone said you
don't understand trump
that's the way he is i mean he wanted
trouble he did
at the capitol did he want violence
did he want them to invade the capitol
he may not have even thought of it
now incitement is not the only charge
that president trump or other organizers
might face
there are seditious conspiracy charges
and
other charges under that section and
grand juries right now are returning
indictments against some of those
rioters
but any investigation a grand jury
investigation into the organizers
of that january 6th event and the ties
they may or may not have to have had to
some of those rioters
that could take a year or longer brian
thanks internet back to discuss the
impeachment trial is one of the youngest
attorneys to graduate from harvard law
at the age of 22
nima romani and co-host terry austin
terry
impeached but not removed the arguments
now surround the wisdom of whether or
not to go after a former president
criminally or civilly what do you think
you know
he is facing charges both criminally and
civilly
state and federal there's no question
that he could be charged on the federal
level because remember
he has not been pardoned as of yet
whether or not biden is interested in
bringing those charges or the doj
and garland if he's you know i'm certain
confirmed we'll see but on the state
level
we know for a fact that new york state
is getting ready to sue him because of
the dealings with the trump foundation
and tax fraud and we also know that in
the state of georgia
they are getting ready to sue him or
they're investigating charges as far as
seditious conspiracy is concerned so
i think he is going to be facing a
number of charges at least
on the state level yeah nima i know you
saw a very familiar gentleman in the
clips prior to that um can you kind of
expand on your thoughts as to the wisdom
of whether or not to prosecute him
either federally or in the states
because we've already seen georgia and
new york
kind of gearing up for that i expect
cyrus james vance jr in new york to move
forward with his investigation and
tax offenses but at the federal level
this president
joe biden merrick garland i think it's
very unlikely they're going to move
forward with the criminal investigation
and a prosecution
everything that president biden has said
has suggested the opposite
and i don't expect this administration
to be in the business
of going after political opponents
especially those that lost
yeah and that might be extremely wise
when you're thinking about it from the
federal
level to not go after him there's a lot
more things that need to be taken care
of in this country
in terms of the covert relief and other
things of that nature but like terry
said
georgia new york definitely looking to
prosecute him there thank you both for
contributing
coming up on law on crime daily did a
wisconsin man kill his wife to be with a
new lover
we take you inside the courtroom opening
statements are after the break
[Music]
a wisconsin man is on trial for the
alleged murder of his wife of 24 years
the only catch police don't have a body
victoria procopovich was reported
missing on april 25
2013. police searched for years but
still haven't found her remains
investigators noticed strange remarks
and actions by the victim's husband
james prokopovic including his new
relationship
with his girlfriend catherine friday the
couple was arrested in 2019
after admitting to lying about meeting
before the victim's disappearance
friday died by suicide last year
prosecutors say prokopovich had the
motive
means an opportunity to kill his wife
the weekend you'll hear after she
disappeared
that weekend
her vicky's daughter marcia is is
reporting that jim's telling her he's
going to get a u-haul
to come and get this out of his house
that he didn't need a place that big
just for him
searchers are reporting overhearing
comments like this you will never find
her
she's not there you're wasting your time
searching that area
during the course of an interview with
law enforcement
the defendant admitted
to being involved in vicki's
disappearance quote okay i'll tell you
okay i'll admit i killed her i killed
her
there i killed her
for retracting that comment a few
moments later
a defendant spoke with other individuals
while in custody that he was 100 sure
that they would never find vicki the
defendant commenting that there would be
no blood or no teeth
that even if they did find her they
wouldn't be able to identify who it was
terry ozin has the defense's version of
events
brian the defense says the victim was
diagnosed with cancer and other medical
ailments that led to her depression
they say she suffered from mental
illness and believed she disappeared on
her own
victoria try to commit suicide
for sure twice you're going to hear
about a garage incident where she tried
to gas herself
where her daughters found her you're
going to hear about a pill overdose
in 2002 right around thanksgiving time
whether son west founder
that's when she said next time no one
will find me
she was upset that they found her he
loved his wife
still loves his wife everybody in this
room wants to know where victoria
prokapovic is
including jim
he wants to know where his wife is we
wouldn't be standing here today
if we knew where she was the fact the
matter is is there is no body
there is no evidence she is gone
when we come back the evidence police
say they have and admit they're missing
in the trial of a wisconsin man accused
of murdering his wife
and disposing of her body still ahead
when wisconsin mother victoria
prokopovic went missing in 2013
she left behind her purse and cell phone
items that made law enforcement
suspicious
so mr profots had told me at
10 pm prior previously
he had seen his wife in the living room
watching tv
and he had gone to bed and it's a small
house there's a little living room
teeny tiny hallway small bedroom that
small dining room and then kitchen so i
had backed up and looked
and i saw that the bed was made the bed
was made
very neatly and very ornately roughly
pillows
and dolls like porcelain face dolls like
laid out
specifically in a bedscape i remember
looking at it all
and thinking that it was odd because mr
pocopovich
got up at 4am
and he said that mrs pro poets wasn't in
bed
so in my mind
mrs propofolics had to come back from
her walk
and make the bed and put all the dolls
and pillows out
or no one had been sleeping in the bed
at all that night
the defense maintains her husband had
nothing to do with her disappearance
and pointed out on cross that
investigators didn't find anything of
value when searching their property
i asked him what had happened and
why he believed why would he believe
that his wife would be missing or
endangered
okay and and that at that indication he
was concerned because his wife's been
suicidal in the past
did you get that information at first
yes that's what he told me
he felt that she liked to walk out
towards the creek and along the roadways
he told me that it wasn't he wasn't
startled by the fact that she was not in
bed with him
because he said that she did sometimes
get up
before him so meaning before 4 a.m
to go out for walks he talked about the
medications and you talked about the
medications that
she was taking because of her mental
health issues right yes
did he show you the pill bottles yes did
you count the number of meds that are in
the pill bottles
i believe i did do you count on the
number of pills to see if they were
consistent with the time they would have
been distributed to the time she would
have
yesterday been missing yes sir but that
wasn't in your report correct
no okay and did you note if any pills
were gone
all right back to discuss murder or
disappearance is
nema romani and terry austin nima nobody
the defense is going with the argument
of
she tried to commit suicide twice and
failed maybe this is the time she was
successful what do you make of that
argument
well it's the only argument that they
have that you know this is a gone girl
situation
or you know suicide but how often do you
see a suicide and the body is never
found
not often and the issue's pocapovich has
been caught in lie
after lie during the interviews
regarding the disappearance of his wife
he's already an admitted liar he's
perjured himself and he's been charged
with that so
even though the normal body the normal
murder weapon they have motivated
opportunities so i expect prosecutors to
be able to move forward and get a guilty
verdict in this case
all right we'll keep eyes on it of
course for the next two weeks terry how
would you compare the prosecution's case
to that of the defenses so far
you know usually i listen to the
prosecution and i do
lean on that side after you hear the
opening but i think the defense has done
a great job
arguing against every allegation so for
instance
the prosecution has said that the
defendant said
they'll never find her well the
explanation is because after her second
suicide attempt she herself said they'll
never find me
you know there are other explanations
like she was
you know subject to him and he was very
controlling one of the things the
defense said
was well he was trying to protect her
because she's depressed and has suicidal
tendencies
so i will just say there are at least
explanations
for almost everything that's going on so
far in this case and i'm impressed by
what the defense is doing
a lot of explanation by the end of the
day the question for those jurors are
is it reasonable and is it guilty beyond
a reasonable doubt of course we'll
continue to follow this case
to let you know nema thank you for
joining us terry thank you as always
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you